[Musique]
depuis la fermeture des mines d'amiante
la région deux têtes folles à
diversifier son économie de façon
spectaculaire
résultat la région manquent cruellement
tomeï de mouvement et a besoin fois ici
à beaucoup d'emplois
nous avions rencontré ismaela et sa
famille en 2010 8,4 après son arrivée au
québec il travaillait encore comme
ouvrier dans une usine alors qu'il a un
baccalauréat en gestion une vaste
expérience on accepte le travail sur le
plancher pour avoir l'expérience
québécois une fois qu'on a l'expérience
donnons nous la chance et l'opportunité
d'exploiter nos diplômes nos expériences
de la vie quatre ans plus tard la
famille conté s'est agrandie garage et
il s'est habitué ou questions sur ses
origines rien ne voit ça l'est comment
ça va gentile à de hauts les chinois
parce qu'il l'a il s'intéresse
elle a beau la nourriture
accès à be a été au front de l'aco vide
dans un chs ld tout en suivant une
formation pour être reconnu comme
infirmière auxiliaire je travaille avec
des collègues mais qu'ils sont
infirmières médecins et c'est ça au beau
pays en afrique mais ici besson faut
commencer par et préposés à proposer on
a beaucoup plus de chance d'avoir
quelqu'un avec un certificat d'ici qu'il
maîtrise de l'extérieur
c'est eva lopez qui nous avait présenté
à la famille comptait arriver de la
colombie il y a trente ans elle a fondé
un organisme qui aide à l'intégration
des immigrants elle voulait faire cette
entrevue dans la halte garderie parce
que le manque de places en services de
garde freine l'intégration des femmes en
particulier les gens qui veulent ces
trains si c'est qu'ils veulent suivre
une formation pour mieux s'organiser
ils peuvent pas parce qu'il n'y a pas
des places en garderie l'intervenante
souligne aussi le manque de classes
d'accueil dans les écoles en région
alors les sans faille et son éthique été
commandés sans faille qui ont des
retards d'apprentissage parce qu'ils
parlent pour la langue sauce est grave
c'est grave parce qu'elle est en train
d'envoyer une génération d'enfants
verdon courbessac
comme ailleurs au québec le prix des
maisons a explosé dans la région le coût
des loyers aussi ici il n'ya pas il n'y
a pas de logements à louer si c'est rare
ici ouais c'est très cher
gilson dollars par mois 1100 dollars
rachid et yousri ont été recrutés par la
boulangerie st-méthode au maroc et en
tunisie ils sont heureux au travail mais
l'éloignement de la famille est
difficile mais un peu de côté parce que
je quitte ma un moment ma petite fait
vraiment beaucoup c'est ça quand rachid
a quitté le maroc il y a trois ans sa
fille n'avait que sept mois il ne l'a
pas revu depuis j'ai trouvé ça dur pour
moi c'est très très dur
parfois
ma passion c'est parti qu'est ce qu'on
demande c'est de simplement accélérer
les processus on utilise aussi beaucoup
d'avoine dans nos pays benoît faucher
embauche une quinzaine de travailleurs
étrangers et en attend une vingtaine
d'autres il sait que pour garder ses
employés ils doivent faire venir leurs
familles même s'il manque de logements
abordables et de places en garderie ya
peut-être pas tout ce ce qu'il faut mais
si mal de travailleurs qui vont
travailler dans nos restaurants c qui
équivaut c'est qui doit faire le pain de
ben merci des dizaines de milliers de
travailleurs temporaires additionnel
serait contre-productif selon eva lopez
ans a cédé au suicide social parce qu'on
n'a pas la capacité il faudrait qu aider
mais matin on décide qu'il ya un budget
extra
s'oublie immense pour pouvoir bâtir des
logements mais c'est demain matin
et
ça lui va bien faire là en forme wii
après avoir fait un certificat à
l'université du québec est passé des
dizaines d'entrevues dans bausch ismaël
a enfin obtenu un poste à la caisse
populaire de tête seulement une il est
conseiller en finances personnelles
début de mandat donc lorsque a eu sa
clientèle effectivement on eu deux ont
reçu les appels de certaines personnes
qui désiraient changer de conseiller et
vous comprendrez que on à tolérance zéro
on n'accepte pas un changement de
conseiller
pour laisser place au racisme ou à la
différence qu'ils dérangent en fait
souvent pendant les périodes eu
d'élection on essaie de tirer sur la
corde commode si tous les problèmes du
monde venez d immigrants il y en a
certains mais j'ai trouvé quand même que
la majorité ici sont ouverts à
l'immigration sont ouverts au monde
depuis les gens sont très accueillants
ismaila accueillis aux portes pendant
six ans avant de trouver un emploi à la
mesure de ses compétences mais il n'a
jamais regretté d'avoir choisi le québec
pour élever sa famille